you know it's funny in England it seems
to me to be a popular format where a lot
of the British talk shows always bring
out like what you do you have at least
two guests on the couch with you and I
as a host would find that very very
difficult I've talked to you about this
before we want our show to feel more
like a dinner party and less like an
interview right so it's about my
favourite point moments in the show are
when we'll go in with you know eight
nine ten questions for a segment and
we'll get to two of them right because
another guest has gone really I do
exactly the same what I do and you and
then someone goes yes I've been to that
restaurant wherever and you're just and
it becomes more of a chat more of a
conversation it's truly is an interview
if I was going on at La I would start by
your show but I wonder who I'd be on the
couch with but I wouldn't I would never
ask because whoever it is it's gotta be
funny yeah would you ever say I don't
want Howard with any guests I just want
to get them alone do you everybody I was
telling you interestingly it's very very
interesting that you would even have
this thought so so I've been listening
to I've been reading a book and I've
been listening to you and over the a lot
over the past few weeks then I saw
watched you on Colbert and I thought
actually actually if you were to come by
a show maybe the most interesting thing
to do is to almost reverse your show on
you and almost do it perhaps even
without an audience just chatting and
talking to you because I think I'm the
more I read your book and since moving
to America the more I've become
absolutely fascinated with your entire
journey I think it's amazing I think
it's kind of inspiring actually the
notion of being able to change publicly
and how you can do that I think is an
incredible thing so when I was watching
on Stephen showers like ah maybe there's
a world where we would we would do that
but then we might back ourselves into a
corner where other guests would go well
Howard was on his own right that might
be the problem yeah that's why I think
the format could be frustrating but what
who cares if you break the format of
your own format it's it's crazy right
yeah I think so and I think these things
are always about evolving
I think you've almost got to evolve
before your audience in a way yes what a
relative become a guy doing its greatest
hit yeah and I think you've always got
to be aware of like when did we change
like I think the Beatles are the best
example of that
like when they came out they had like
moptop haircuts and more like cool and
their before anybody realized they had
long hair and was singing Lucy in the
Sky with Diamonds and you're like you've
got to evolve before your audience
you've got to take them with you yes
rather than sit stagnant in this in the
water you know